bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur arte france comment est ce que
vous vous expliquer ce regain du nom de
contamination au cornadis en france il
ya deux de réseau en gros elle le fait
qu' on a davantage de concentration
populationnelle avec des déplacements de
populations en zones estivale en zone de
villégiature on voit bien que l'on à des
endroits où vous avez habituellement
5000 10000 habitants qui passe tout d'un
coup à deux cent mille deux cent
cinquante villes et on a une période qui
est favorise le un petit peu les
rapprochements on va dire et l'oubli des
mesures barrières donc ça c'est une
chose et qu'ensuite on multiplie les
tests on est à 380 mille tests par
semaine on est dans la configuration du
mois de marx à peu près un nombre de
deux de patients contaminés en
augmentation sauf que au moins deux
marques sont testés cinquante mille fois
par semaine là on est à 3 180 milles et
que au mois de mars on avait déjà des
ddd
malheureusement des gens qui étaient
décédées de la pathologie et c'est le
chiffre des décès était en augmentation
alors que là on voit qu'il stagne donc
sonné dans une alerte qui est sérieuse
dont il faut tenir compte avec une
augmentation chaque semaine mais on a
pas de cas graves
fort heureusement parce que les gens qui
développent des symptômes graves qui
sont à risque se protège beaucoup plus
les gens âgés ont parfaitement compris
quels étaient les risques pour eux de
cette pathologie
la question des tests puisque vous
l'abordez plus de tests sont réalisés on
est quand même loin des 1 720 tests qui
sont qui était premier chaque semaine
comment est ce qu'on peut faire face à
l'afflux de demandes qui finalement est
ce que ce n'est pas plutôt une bonne
nouvelle en soi que les gens se teste
davantage
c'est une excellente nouvelle on
rappelle que les 700 mille tests étaient
annoncées pour le 11 mai lors du
discours le 28 avril du premier ministre
sur le déconfinement on est le 24
juillet et on est à 388 est donc on est
mauvais sur l'organisation des tests
les gens ont compris qu'il fallait se
tester je crois qu'il faut que l'on
ouvre largement aux tests sans doute
faut-il que les médecins puissent tester
également sans doute faut-il que l'on
puisse tester dans pas mal d'endroits du
territoire en plus des laboratoires et
puis surtout surtout sans doute faut-il
que l'on passe au test salivaire
faut qu'on accélère et cette mise en
place des tests salivaires qui sont des
tests qui peuvent être plus rapides dans
leurs résultats et puis surtout qu'ils
ne sont pas traumatique et vous savez
que le test les cui maj nasale le test
par rt pcr avec un bateau l'est que l'on
vous met dans les narines est pas un
test qui est très agréable et qui rebute
certains nombre de personnes qui par
contre ont peur d'aller se faire tester
donc on a un phénomène de regroupement
un peu comme les bouchons sur les
autoroutes pendant les vacances on a
beaucoup de demandes et on a des goulots
d'étranglement et puis on a un test qui
est de un petit peu traumatique qui fait
que certaines personnes ne se pas se
faire tester pour changer tout ça le
masque est également obligatoire dans
l'espace public clos depuis lundi ce que
c'était la bonne décision à prendre est
ce qu'elle n'arrive pas un peu tard
alors la bonne décision à prendre
oui évidemment puisque vous savez qu'on
a signé des tribunes on a été plusieurs
médecins a signé deux tribunes de façon
à obtenir cette obligation du masque un
lieu clos est ce que cela aurait dû être
pris beaucoup plus tôt évidemment
évidemment je vous rappelle que les
premières alertes que nous avons lancée
sur le port du masque un lieu clos
c'était le métro les transports en
commun à l'époque c'était le 9 mars le 9
mars et on a obligé le port du masque
dans le métro le 11 mai on a perdu
énormément de temps trop de temps on a
eu très probablement c'est grave de dire
ça mais c'est la réalité très
probablement des milliers de morts qui
pouvait être évitable et qui ne l'ont
pas été parce qu'on n'a pas voulu mettre
l'accent sur des véritables mesures
barrières voilà tout le temps considéré
le masque commune un petit peu
subalternes et complémentaires c'était
les mots du gouvernement alors qu'on
voit bien que il y à une aérosols
isation on a prévenu là dessus depuis
des mois et cet aérosol isation des le
principal vecteur du virus
mais justement lent très concrètement
qu'est ce que cela signifie que dans un
lieu clos même masque même si la
distanciation social et est respectée
sans le masque on risque quand même
d'être contaminé par le col d'agnès je
vous donne une image très parlant d'
imaginer la fumée d'une cigarette
vous avez connu ces zones avant de
carbone qu'on l'interdise le tabac dans
les temps les lieux publics au col et
s'épousent des pièces où vous aviez 50
fumeurs et vous aviez un nuage carrément
qui stagnait de fumer quand vous fumer
une cigarette avec
d'ailleurs ce nuage il est évacué tout
de suite il ne reste pas mais à
l'intérieur comme vous avez un lieu clos
ces nuages persistent et b ce nuage
c'est le nuage virale quand vous avez
plusieurs personnes qui respire du virus
dans une pièce et que les fenêtres sont
fermées vous finissez par avoir un
véritable nuage virale que tout le monde
respire et l'idée l'idée de porter le
masque un lieu clos l'idée que chacun
porte le masque un lieu clos c'est
d'éviter d'aérosols ise et donc d'éviter
de créer ce nuage est de diminuer la
concentration virale qui lie à un stylet
en suspension dans l'air et donc de fait
de diminuer les risques de contamination
d'un lot est ce que selon vous la france
est prête aujourd'hui à faire face à une
deuxième vague comment est ce que vous
voyez à les prochaines semaines alors
prête ce qui est certain c'est que les
plus aguerris à la lutte contre cette
maladie
d'abord on la connaît mieux ensuite donc
la partie soignantes et plus aguerris la
partie populationnelle et plus aguerris
également hélas elle a compris également
un certain nombre de choses
ensuite dire que l'on est prêt ça veut
dire faire confiance au commandement
or si vous voulez nous médecins nous
soignons nous avons été tellement
maltraitée entre guillemets on nous a
tellement menti sur la présence des
moyens de protection on a pris tellement
de retard on nous a tellement peu
écoutés que il reste fort doutes quant à
la capacité du commandement à organiser
une vraie une vraie prise en une vraie
mise en place des moyens si par cas on
avait une deuxième vague donc sonné plus
aguerris on est prêts on fera face vous
dire que on part la fleur au fusil en
disant ça va bien se passer
ça ça serait présomptueux merci beaucoup
jérôme marty on suivra évidemment
l'évolution de la situation avec
attention le rappelle est que vous êtes
président du syndicat ma femme elle
l'union française pour une médecine
merci